hey guys this is andrew for
trainsenses.com so in this video i would
like to make a big update guys on
gamestop it's been a while i haven't
talked about gme because nothing much
was happening but i think we have an
interesting situation so i want to talk
about it as i will do every time i'm
gonna see an interesting situation so
let's get into it and see what the chats
are telling us
[Music]
all right so let's take a step back you
guys so i'm on the daily time frame i
want to show you two things here
so the first thing i want to show you is
that we are bullish right because what
is the definition of a bull market is
making high highs high lows and trading
above the moving averages so we are
making here definitely higher lows we
are not able to make higher highs since
feb 21 i mean gen 21 end of jan which
means we are in a corrective phase since
january 21 okay that a label a b c d e
according to eliot wave theory that is
telling me this might be a huge triangle
guys that often happen in force waves so
that makes sense and potentially if we
have an upset breakout so i see the
breakout level on my hand around 250
then this would be the signal that the
fifth wave is coming all right
and what is interesting to see
so like i said guys we are bullish
because we are both the moving averages
so we are actually below the 20 in the
50 period moving average but we are
above the 200 day moving average that is
at 161 so i think it's pretty
interesting to see that we are having
actually a very nice opportunity here
so of course there's no guarantee we
hold above 160
to
61 all right uh but technically it's a
nice entry level and we are having if i
zoom in a little bit guys on the short
term we having a breakout here
short-term breakouts we have two doji
candle consecutive so this is the
confirmation of a breakout all right one
candle in the timeframe you're
considering is a breakout it can be
played but it's not confirmed and when
you have a second day above then it's
confirmed so here maybe we're gonna have
some buying uh orders coming on monday
let me just
finish on the short term we have in here
we don't have a bullish divergence on
the short term do we
okay we slightly have it all right so
you can see here the momentum is picking
up okay on the hourly time frame
that's not obvious okay i'm checking if
you have a bullish divergence market
making lower lows okay from here
september to end of september and the
momentum is going slightly higher so we
have a beginning of a bullish divergence
which when it's associated with the
breakout is giving you a more trustful
signal let me show you quickly guys the
divergences so this is the one i was
referring to market in blue making lower
lows and the momentum going higher so
this is usually bullish uh but we've
seen those divergences happening many
times without being followed by a strong
move up so here we have the divergence
on the aodi only it's better to have it
on the four hours time frame as well
which means that the medium term
momentum is shifting to here you can see
the momentum is going lower on the first
time frame so this divergence is not
powerful but we have a break the
breakout that is going with it so it's a
kind of good signal to me i think we
still might see a bit more downside like
you know some some kind of a re-test
here
so i don't think i mean
this is not a signal that is saying that
on monday we're gonna go higher it's a
signal that you know it's looking pretty
good we might uh go and find some
support again at the 200 day moving
average and then you know what we're
looking for is something like this this
would be the signal that we are ready
for another thing i wanted to show you
guys because once again this is a
long-term game all right i think
everybody understands that and that's
why i think it's interesting sometimes
to just look at the long-term signals
and i just showed you that on the short
term we have something bullish so let's
see if we have the bullish reaction we
expect but look at the long term we are
above the we're making higher lows okay
we have an upward
here support trend line that is actually
so connecting the lows here and that is
giving us a support as well at 162. so
this is bullish we have an upward
support trendline
and most importantly guys look it's not
easy to spot but when you're on a daily
time frame you can see that here the
market
made low higher
lows
and in the same time the momentum was
making lower lows so
this is a divergence hidden one i'm
going to show you this right away but
just
think about it twice because it's
actually making a lot of sense the
momentum is shifting lower which means
that birds are in control because they
have the momentum with them and
even having the momentum with them
they're not able to push the market
making a new low so the divergence is
that the momentum shifting lower but the
price action making higher lows so this
is this one guys
hidden
bullish divergence so on the daily time
frame we have a hidden bullish
divergence and on the short term we have
a bullish regular divergence so we have
the divergences with us we have the
moving averages with us we have the
trend line with us and we have a small
breakout so i mean technically it's
looking good we only miss the breakout
above the orange trend line to be
looking really really great and if this
happens let me just remind you guys
i know that some of you probably think
this guy is crazy you know he's never
gonna give up and the truth is that
maybe i would one day if things don't
look good anymore but for now they're
looking good all right so i'm gonna keep
telling you what uh what i think might
happen
so i think that what might happen is
that we get this upset breakout and then
we have a run
to the 800 area the 1.618 level all
right this is uh idiot wave theory that
they apply to gamestop and it gave quite
good results in the past it didn't work
here but it worked in many other ways so
i think it might work again
and
what i want to show you guys here that
is very important because this is all
related to what is happening on the
option market and the short market i
mean you know
this stock is still heavily shorted so
what do we see here the regular short
first i get it here guys is 11 so very
stable but the synthetic shot is at
seven percent right now not sorry gme is
not at 200 yet
so the synthetic shot is at 5 but the
maximum synthetic shot is at 25 so let
me explain again what this means it
means that right now there is uh if you
compute all the options delta exposure
you have five percent but if all these
options are deep in the money then the
delta would be equal to 100 okay the
delta is the exposure you have for each
option so the more in the money the more
exposure you get and this delta would
converge towards one and if this happens
it means gme is going for example i
don't know to
800 you can see that the synthetic shot
is converging towards the maximum
synthetic shot what does it mean it
means that 20 of the float would be both
by market makers on the upside so this
is what we call gamma okay this is the
the gamma is just the difference of
delta when the spot moves up or down and
here you can see that whenever the spot
moves the synthetic short is
so let me sum up the situation
technically we have everything that is
looking good we have on the option
market it's more animated than almost
ever so i here recalled
most of i guess on gme i had on the 26
sorry so let me add this one bam i move
it here so this one is wrong
okay so you can see we have two percent
more than two months ago all right so
two months ago the synthetic shot was
bigger
because the spot was at 205 but the
maximum synthetic shot was smaller what
does it mean it means that people still
believe in it and that it is still
growing and the best way to see it is
when you open it
i'm not going to go in too much into
detail i just can tell you that most of
the options are coming from gen 22 so
from here you can see i'm looking for
the greens
so i have also here a big one and here
so okay
let's be honest october and november we
have a lot of options as well so let's
see if they are rolled but
the biggest one is the 950 strike on the
maturity gen 22
so this means that if something is to
happen
it would probably happen before gen 22
because
after that
we lose the gamma so let's see maybe
it's going to be rolled if nothing
happens i'm still gonna be there guys to
talk about what i see and talk about
what might happen i'm here giving you
the market dynamics guys once again when
i talk about ta i talk about momentum i
talk about supports and resistance i
talk about who is in control
and then i show you the synthetic short
and the regular shot which is giving you
the information about the gamma so the
market dynamics and who might do what in
which scenario and i can tell you that
if gamestop breaks 250 on the upside
everybody's gonna be buyer
so that's it for today guys i hope you
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click on the sub like
and bell button so you're gonna be the
first to know when i upload anything new
and stay close to shore see you guys